hi guys how's it going it's very late at
night which means that I'm a little bit
loopy and very tired but that's okay I
had some stuff in the morning that I
needed to take care of so I'm recording
this in the evening prior so that it'll
be ready for you guys and not late which
is something that I've been doing a lot
not entirely my fault YouTube has been
really messing up on its processing
things have been taking like three or
four times as long as they usually do
but thank you again guys for your
patience um also I'm going to be going
to Comic Con this week so I will have
videos ready for that and they should
all be scheduled which means that
they'll be more regular than they ever
have been because I made them way in
advance but other than that this past
weekend has been interesting because
it's been very self-reflective which is
a thing that I do a lot but but in this
particular case it's been about you know
my past beyond YouTube and I often talk
about what I think about on YouTube and
for what I've done on YouTube but since
I played that dragon cancer you know
I've been thinking about you know my my
younger days back when I still had the
vibrancy of youth core things through my
veins but I've been thinking about my
dad and you know my childhood and and me
growing up and and also thinking back on
old videos that I've done of course but
but in this circle circle the one thing
that stood out that I wanted to talk
about in this vlog was the concept of
believing in yourself and it's a it's a
subject that I've talked about a lot and
it's something that I reinforced but
those are just words
you know believe in yourself those are
words it's not an instruction manual on
how to be better in your life and not
that I'm qualified to tell you guys how
to do that but I am qualified to tell
you guys how I've lived my life and how
that's worked for me and one of the most
important things is something that I
constantly need to remind myself of is
that I don't have anything to prove to
anyone and that may seem like a bold
claim because I do have a lot of
expectations to meet both with you guys
and myself but one of the things that
always keeps me grounded is realizing
that I don't owe anybody anything simply
existing doesn't mean that you
have a debt that you need to pay to the
universe to exist you exist whether or
not you think and let yourself be
stressed out by those ideas and this is
a very grandiose topic but trust me I'm
going to bring it down into something
cohesive that could be understood but
this whole concept of not owing anyone
anything may seem sensible at its face
but something it's sometimes it's very
hard to get through in your day-to-day
life because especially in the age of
the Internet
you're constantly comparing yourself to
other people and you're constantly
comparing yourself to other like people
in your field of study that may be
better than you are at what you're doing
there may be a better artist better
musicians better you know youtubers it
doesn't matter what subject it is I like
you'll often find yourself comparing
yourself to others and you'll sometimes
feel like you owe it to yourself to be
that good and that is a horrible way of
thinking because that may motivate you
in the short term and you'll be able to
like get a lot of [ __ ] you energy is
what I call it but in all honesty that
isn't what really is going to make you
go the farthest because when you are
constantly trying to meet the
expectations of someone else you're
letting yourself down and one of the
things that's been hard for me to
understand in my life is this concept
that I don't need to focus on anyone
else I don't need to compare myself to
anyone except myself that's why I look
back on my life so much because I'm not
comparing myself to other youtubers I'm
not comparing myself to other artists or
voiceover artists or or actors if I want
to do their thing I'm not comparing to
other people I'm comparing to my past
self and this may be yesterday maybe
years ago it may be like my childhood
self those are the only people in my
life that I need to compare myself to
and hopefully as I go through my life
I'm constantly getting better I can look
back on my past self and I can be proud
of what I've accomplished in the past
for when it was
so you know where you've come from and
you know where you're going because
hopefully you've got a goal in mind and
I've actually talked about this in a
video called believe in yourself where I
believe I was riding a bike and talking
about this but I meant it then and I
mean it now you have a goal in mind and
this is a goal that just drives you
forward it's what you burn for in the
middle of the night it's what you lose
sleep for it is everything that consumes
your life this goal is what you want
more than anything in the world and it's
right there waiting for you to take it
and it's literally right there and it's
what do you want more than anything in
the world and that's what happened to me
once I found YouTube I wanted to be a
youtuber so badly and I knew there were
dozens hundreds of other people trying
to make YouTube happen and I if I had
compared myself to them and helped
myself to their standard from the get-go
I would never have been anywhere I would
have been wallowing him self-doubt and
self-pity and how oh I don't have as
many subscribers as them I'll never get
there I set out only to do the best that
I could I could not live if I held
myself to their standards and waited for
their approval
I had to approve myself and I had held
myself to my own standards and my
standards are really high my my
standards may not see mine when I'm
being asinine and childish in front of
the camera but my standards for what I
do in my life are high because I've been
increasing them every year that I've
been alive I expect more out of myself
I expect better out of myself I expect
better out of myself everyday and that
all comes from the fact that I believe
in what I do and that's not to say I
ignore outside opinions I don't even
ignore like people that lash out at me
for what I've done in the past
I don't ignore that I take that in
and I addressed that for what it is and
I I influence and shape my life around
it but at the end of the day I make
things that I'm proud of I make things
that make me laugh I make things that
make me smile and it's kind of a selfish
way of thinking but and even though I
would like suggest you guys to be
selfless and help those around you at
the end of the day you are you and you
have you to take care of it and a lot of
you guys out there don't take care of
yourself you give yourself to others and
you give yourself to others and and some
of you may do it selflessly and not
expect anything back some of you may
expect something back but you give out
more than you give to yourself and you
gotta believe in yourself you gotta be
good to yourself you gotta be good to
the person that you are cuz you're all
you got till the end of your days
friends may come and go you may have
lifelong partners but you'll always have
yourself and you have to be happy with
what you got and if you're not happy you
gotta make that goal you gotta make that
go and you gotta make it happen no
matter what
I'm glad we're out as it please shape
our words just do it and all that stuff
but I mean it so much I've said it
before I'll say it a million times I
believe in you guys I'm a walking
testament to the fact that you can
literally do anything that you want but
you gotta believe in yourself so that is
the point that I wanted to make tonight
in in this vlog more than anything
because it's been on my mind this whole
weekend and I use these vlogs it's just
a way to say whatever the hell's on my
mind and take it for what you will but I
hope it helps somebody out there just
know that I believe in you if you don't
believe in yourself yet I do so thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you for sticking with my crazy ramblings
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye